hey guys it's chrissy teigen and i tend
up hey guys I'm here with tasty and
we're gonna be cooking up my jalapeno
cheddar corn pudding and you're gonna
love it
so this dish was actually one of my
earliest earliest recipes I started it
on my blog this is the way that we'd
love to do it at our house you know you
just want something nostalgic when
you're eating around the holidays hey
Google cook with tasty welcome to tasty
uh-huh this mine just my jalapeno
cheddar corn pudding first step cutting
the corn off the cob with my trusty
bundt pan I always make a ton of sides
for Thanksgiving I mean I care about it
more than the turkey I care about it
more than my protein I'm like I need 20
different sides and this is kind of the
star of the show this corn pudding
because it's nice and sweet it's
nostalgic there's so many memories
around it BAM
corn starch is important it makes it
nice and thick it makes it all bind
together so it's not just like your
regular old flowing creamed corn it
makes it like a casserole which is
delicious all right gonna whisk it up
and it nice and smooth get those lumps
out
I am a staunch supporter of the no
breakfast team you can't have breakfast
on Thanksgiving
stop having dinner at 3:00 this is crazy
there's nothing it's still a day you can
still eat at like a normal dinner time
just have a little snack here and there
that's why I put out the deviled eggs
but no no sit-down breakfast you should
stick with your egg those jalapenos
don't touch them
there should absolutely be seeds in
jalapeno I think that's what gives it
its heat its flavor
obviously the seeds do cause issue make
sure to use gloves and honestly I have
kids now I have definitely omitting
seeds more than I used to any parent
knows they're always thinking about
their tummies or their poops haveli is
offer or like their next two how's
school gonna be if they have this
ingredient helping is a dangerous
business what I love just kind of give
it a good fold I wouldn't say
aggressively mix it we want to keep
those kernels nice and big we don't want
to pound them out too much but make sure
all the yolks are broken pick that up
that's good next we're gonna add our
butter
we gotta melt it again the holiday
season is all about family and all about
food and I think of the kind of
atmosphere that we're gonna create for
our families do I want to do a sit-down
dinner enjoy one at buffet style is
everyone gonna be on the couch but we're
still always going to Center it around
family coming together I have a really
small family so it's so cool for my
small family to get together with his
large family because they all genuinely
get along top with the cheddar that you
kept write them and then pop it into the
oven
[Music]
hey Google start a timer for 50 minutes
hey Google show me a trick for peeling
garlic hey Google how many cups in a
pint two cups of beer is that Patrick
hey Google how do you eat a lobster hey
Google how much time is left on the
timer t-minus three seconds boom boom
coming in look how good that looks oh it
smells so good to it you are gonna love
this there you have it
it looks delicious it's nice and warm I
can't wait to dig in that is so so good
hey Google give me some applause
[Applause]
[Music]